les petits bateaux sur france inter jean
marc jancovici est ingénieur enseignants
à mines paristech
il a écrit énormément lire nous allons
parler peut-être ici du changement
climatique expliqué à ma fille édité au
seuil et bien victor tuer beaucoup plus
sage qu'un certain nombre d'adultes qui
affirme que l'électricité ne pollue pas
et qui ont parfaitement tordre à huy des
adultes il y en a beaucoup par exemple
et constructeur de voitures électriques
disent volontiers que leurs voitures ne
pollue pas parce que ça marche à
l'électricité
les constructeurs de trains à hydrogène
disent que leur train ne pollue pas
parce que l'hydrogène ne fait que de la
vapeur d'eau quand on s'en sert web
elles n'ont pas cette fumée noire
spectaculaire exactement est en fait
s'il peut y avoir la fumée noire mais
ailleurs en fait il faut repartir du
début
l'électricité on n'en trouve pas dans la
nature prêtes à l'emploi
alors il ya un endroit où on trouve de
l'électricité dans la nature c'est dans
les éclairs d'orage mais c'est pas tout
à fait prêt à l'emploi
parce que si j'essayais de faire
fonctionner radio france avec les
éclairs d'orage aujourd'hui ça
marcherait pas bien donc cette
électricité il faut que je la fabrique
avec autre chose et cette autre chose
s'appelle une centrale électrique
alors comment est-ce qu'on fabrique de
l'électricité aujourd'hui dans le monde
et bien en france on pense beaucoup
centrales nucléaires en fait c'est 15%
de l'électricité qu'on fait dans le
monde une personne sur six seulement qui
utilise de l'électricité ça vient du
nucléaire dans le monde
et l'essentiel de l'électricité ou la
fabrique avec du charbon alors ça marche
de la manière suivante le charbon ça
brûle avec cette chaleur je vais créer
de la vapeur
je vais faire bouillir de l'eau et créer
de la vapeur et cette vapeur elle va
servir à faire tourner une turbine une
turbine ça ressemble un peu à un moteur
d'avion un truc avec des ailettes là qui
tourne sauf que ça marche pas exactement
de la même manière mais c'est le même
principe
et quand ça tourne cette turbine
savamment traîner un alternateur un
alternateur c'est un moteur à l'envers
un moteur électrique je rentre de
l'électricité ça se met à tourner un
alternateur je rentre du mouvement je
fais tourner et ça me sort de
l'électricité voilà c'est comme ça que
ça marche et je finis à l'arrivée par
avoir de l'électricité
mais dans cette affaire-là il a fallu
que j'aille chercher du charbon ça
pollue un peu il a fallu que je fasse
brûler alors ça ça pollue autant qu'on
veut
parce que non seulement ça fait du gaz
carbonique qui est un gaz à effet de
serre mais ça fait des poussières mais
ça fait des particules mais ça fait
descendre en quantité considérable qui
derrière vont faire de la pollution
locale donc la production d'électricité
au charbon est quelque chose qui
polluent de plein de manières
différentes et une fois que cette
électricité est arrivée jusque dans une
voiture ou une cafetière effectivement
là où on s'en sert ça ne pollue plus
mais la fumée noire on peut très bien la
voir ailleurs le grand paradoxe par
exemple c'est que si je fais une voiture
électrique et que je fais l'électricité
au charbon eh bien j'ai simplement des
portes et la pollution au lieu de
production de l'électricité
mais globalement pour la planète ça me
fait autant de gaz carbonique même plus
en fait
et autant de poussière et de particules
même plus donc oui l'électricité pollue
elle pollue autant que la manière de la
faire donc avec du charbon et bien c'est
l'extraction du charbon est la pollution
du charbon avec du gaz ce même principe
on fait brûler du gaz ils ont fait
tourner une turbine
ça pollue moins parce que le gaz serait
pas de poussière mais il fait quand même
du co2 ensuite je peux en faire et du
pétrole nous on fait encore un peu avec
du pétrole dans le monde
je peux en faire avec du nucléaire à ce
moment ça fait pas de co2 saad autre
inconvénient il faut que je m'occupe des
déchets et enfin je peux en faire avec
des chutes d'eau c'est les barrages et à
ce moment là pollution c'est que j'ai
noyé des vallées qui du coup ne sont
plus disponibles pour y laisser les
espèces qui y vivaient avant
donc il n'ya pas de manière totalement
propre de faire de l'électricité
et quand on parle des panneaux solaires
ou des éoliennes en dix ans est
totalement propre c'est aussi quelque
chose qui est une approximation plus ou
moins valables
il a fallu faire le panneau solaire il a
fallu faire l'éolienne donc à nouveau
c'est aller chercher les matériaux dans
des mines faire de la chimie faire de la
métallurgie transporter tout ça est donc
à chaque fois il faut calculer c'est
pour ça que c'est un peu difficile et il
ya un certain nombre de gens qui
préfèrent se raconter des histoires en
disant tout ça c'est zéro parce que là
où je me sers de l'électricité c'est
propre mais en fait il faut raisonner
sur l'ensemble de ce qui s'est passé et
à ce moment l'électricité c'est aussi
propre que la manière de le faire est
aussi propre ou pas propre plus
exactement que la quantité d'électricité
que j'ai produites et bien ça c'est dit